[Music]
we brought together five women and had
them rank each other based on their
dating profiles then five men rearranged
them based on how dateable their
profiles looked
this
is a ranking
okay so i am on hinge that's my favorite
app my first prompt here is let me
introduce you to my alter ego this is a
picture of me on set i'm like full glam
like i don't normally look like this i'm
a content creator i also am a model and
that's like a big dream of mine got to
let them know i have some friends and
then my life behind the scenes is a
little bts video that i made from one of
my photo shoots little booty too hello
booty
just a little bit you know all right my
app of choice is tinder because i love
this super like function i love to know
that a guy's really into me and
therefore pursue the conversation so my
first picture is a picture of myself
eating because i love to eat and then i
have a picture of me with lights because
i'll light up your world
a picture of me
in this like really risque outfit
because sometimes i like to put on a
little show for people i got a little
too tipsy and try to steal a
cheeseburger so i just want to let them
know that even if i'm drunk i'll still
take care of them
that's not what this means
that's not what this means
that's that's not what it's that's not
what this means
when you're drunk you steal stuff that's
what we're gonna take from it why she's
stealing a cheeseburger
it's random put it in your purse now
you're
not you're not going to go live bro
there's been times where girls have
pulled [ __ ] out of their personality
but just one shoe yeah
yeah
what she's got a big purse got [ __ ] that
don't belong there yay
what's the weirdest thing you've seen a
girl pull out of purse
a hammer
[Laughter]
why are you going to the club with a
hammer [ __ ]
yeah of course i'm going to take your
goddamn hammer give me the hammer wait
wait wait you're bouncing you were
bouncing right yeah okay go ahead
i'm not supposed to pat [ __ ]
down but she didn't have a big outfit so
i'm like okay well let me look in your
purse right there's a whole hammer
there's a hammer
and not like a hammer i'm gonna tell i'm
gonna tell you what type of hammer that
they have yeah this [ __ ]
one of them sledgehammers
it was a mallet no it was a mallet
that's what it was it's one of them
video game hammers i know you're talking
about how to talk about it but metal
i'm like huh why don't you have it
that's what she had yeah why does she
have i don't know
you know what she told me
you know what she told me oops i forgot
it in there what
how maybe she works in construction
with your purse
no it's a toolbox
it's not a purse it's a tuba a hat
put in the car a hammer guys and ladies
what's the weirdest thing you've seen in
a woman's purse or a woman what do you
put what's the weirdest thing you put in
your purse a hammer all right here we go
and my bio says do you have back pain
headaches stomachaches it's probably
because you're bending over backwards
and stressing over someone who isn't
feeding you right now with the new
improved gloria you can feel it easy
together
hey you know [ __ ] a lot
it's just fine i mean
you put some effort into her profile i
am mad at you
okay
normal regular picture not my favorite
picture ever not my worst but i feel
like this is in general what i look like
and then this is my dog
paisley
guess the back story of this photo um i
just turned 24 on the third
and i had all my friends dressed up as
pickles uh for medieval times lots of
people took pictures with us we're the
same type of weirdo as a kid you also
collected rocks and when they would
break slash crack you held funerals for
them in your backyard
[Applause]
you know i always say this dudes dudes
dudes are terrible taking pictures right
that's why their dating profiles suck
um
and then guys need to be told that their
pictures so yeah
yes ladies you need to be told that
y'all are like [ __ ] lame a lot of the
times your pickup lines your pictures
some of them just like corny zelda lane
and this is me falling
but i'm okay but i'm okay so my app of
choice is bumble because i
like the throughout like my little
pickup line if you had to choose what
kitchen utensil would you be a fork i'd
like to fork you
[Music]
i'm just gonna be something corny about
i'm sorry well i want to be enough
because i want to cut through the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah i want to be a spoon
because i can't wait to spoon you
let me be your little spoon to vomit you
want to be a big spoon to my little
spoon from some corner like that watch
fork what fork
i'm forking
i know that's pretty good too
something like a pan because i think you
and i were gonna pan out
and then they'll be like oh a spatula i
don't know like what about you and be
like i wanna be a little spoon
[Music]
sorry
remember what i told you [ __ ]
about how women suck at lines and like
making the first move like they they're
terrible but it's okay so we did
something
but holy [ __ ] when i was on these dating
guys the women make the first message
i'm telling you it was garbage
and then i put a little like risque
photo of me at the beach it's not risque
that's you at that beach not me she got
her broad the titty meat's a little bit
out i'm not risky that's not risky
risque is relative
fair right showing ankles in saudi
arabia that's risque she's got asian
parents yeah yeah yeah over here [ __ ]
but if your asian parents follow you you
go to cuba or you go to [ __ ] puerto
rico right if if there you have anything
more on than pasties
that's not risky
that's how it'll be yeah but go to saudi
arabia show off your ankles everyone
like
right so everything is like [ __ ] yes
200
stones
stones and money so everything is
relative to the location
inhale
okay so this is me on hinge i don't
smoke drink or do anything so people
usually like she's boring for me
but i like to have fun i swear uh i want
someone who is passionately pursuing
their purpose in life relationships come
and go but what motivates you to wake up
every day will always remain i put that
because i feel like sometimes i meet
guys and they're like oh i just like
money or drugs or like i'm like okay but
like what else
see i i'm not actually not mad at that
because at least at the very least if a
guy is reading the profile he knows
you're there for something a little bit
more serious from from that so i'm not
mad at folks stating that kind of stuff
because i think it is helpful in terms
of weeding people out you know because
if you do the opposite you're like i'm
just here for a good time not a long
time dudes will be like oh we [ __ ]
i'm going in with that intention i'm
[ __ ] you and mine so far and then
this picture was from halloween it's
actually a trap because
it's just like a lot of booty meat out
and if they like that picture first i'm
like i automatically don't
that's too bad that's a trap that's too
bad she put a trash she said she put out
a picture that dudes are gonna like and
if they like it then she get mad
i don't care i saw booty meat so
all right ranking them which one do you
think is going first
most to
last date ability though database it's
not the same thing datability is like
what like in terms of relationship to
ideas so how do you think it's gonna how
can i think it's gonna go they're gonna
put that girl with the
burgundy blazer on this girl the girl in
the middle then the girl with the curly
hair right here
so one two three four five okay i'm
actually gonna go black girl is gonna go
first and then i'm gonna say the girl in
the middle is gonna go second i'm gonna
say the other black girl's gonna go
third she's gonna go fourth and i think
she's gonna go last
they're doing date abilities because
she's on tinder also because they're
ranking themselves she's on tinder also
they're on the image yeah okay yeah
um i'm gonna go ahead and put me last
because i know i'm like just a walking
red flag
hey you know what gloria gloria let me
show you some love i appreciate you
because if you know your communist china
i can at least respect it
right
i can appreciate that you know
and so if you have some self-awareness
it's the first step and fight
for them
what translates to
a crazy [ __ ] i know she's a crazy [ __ ]
is less crazy than the crazy [ __ ] i
don't know if she's a crazy [ __ ] max
i might go for the last spot just
because i feel like my profile is like
kind of basic and also like hinge gives
you a lot of prompts to like actually
really showcase yourself and i feel like
like with bumble like it just doesn't
have that and so i'm going to put my i'm
going to preserve this one for me
put me right here i want to put my phone
down in the fourth spot because i feel
like you don't know that much about me
from my page i think a dating profile
the point is like a little bit and then
they can message you and you guys figure
each other out so i think you have a
pretty good profile and it shows like
you're creative as well with your
content creation but then you also need
to go further up because you have a lot
of conversation starters like what are
you getting at first yes why are you
wrapping things up
all
right
okay okay
let's put that there okay
wait you're in the last one my profile
is so basic what are we arguing it's not
basically all you shared so many things
like i know exactly what you're looking
for from your page i'm gonna make a
switch right here while you had such
good like conversation starters it shows
like that you've traveled so much and
it's just like a lot of your personality
and your profiles i remember things
about your profile
like
i think you should definitely be up here
really maybe i'm gonna move myself
at least at least i love yours i'm gonna
move
yours
she's traveled a lot she's got a lot to
share your page is fun and it's exciting
and i am enticed to go on a date with
you so that's why i think it should be
number one oh
okay
you were closer than me
they're all just fine to be last no no
because i'm ugly
you know how that goes
you know how that goes you know this
would not be the same for dudes
no
all right whatever you don't be the
ugliest bro go ahead
sure sure
no i'm the other no no it'll be you
you're so pretty you're so engaging i'm
ugly
yeah
that's right yeah brother two out of ten
yeah yeah [ __ ] you kind of ugly yeah
yeah i mean
i don't look at you too long because i'm
gay but like yeah you love me
[Music]
monica okay so she's she's she a model i
like to see her in in a natural
environment with some friends maybe a
candid
[ __ ] are you just doing modeling use
one of them fancy girls okay okay
that's that's good that's it that's good
that's that's good all right grace 23.
don't fight unless you okay
hey we got a little bit of freaks myself
some dick
gobble
[Music]
or something
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah wait till you see my dick where do
you see my dick and he goes a little
something like damn
damn
damn
damn all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
so here's my thing right guys
tinder
response honest honesty respectfully
it's a little more short term okay
[Laughter]
that's not what that means i'm gonna
take care of you
you steal [ __ ] when you drunk that's
what it means next is molly dating me
will look like what does that mean
you would look like and look like her oh
huh
best travel story getting stranded on a
nude beach in mexico when the boat ran
out of gas i need somebody that like if
there's a problem i need a solution yes
the backstory of this photo okay that
looks fun
cucumbers i honestly i didn't see your
face very much give me a nice
well-framed headshot
this guy this guy is like a photographer
on set [ __ ] look here look here yes i
wanna
in your environment
okay row like a tiger now kristen that's
a lovely first photo yeah smile simple
that's a lovely first photo smile uh-huh
got her lively outfit
it's like they went to the face they
skipped something and then they went to
the rest what if they were to face it
with smiles
straight up
because you have to understand we got
two brains right we got the brain up
here and the brain there this one
doesn't always talk sometimes what it
says gets stuck right here so our mouth
will be like you know you're an
absolutely lovely girl with a fantastic
personality right in the middle of
someone's like [ __ ] i can't wait to
stick my dick inside your cheeks right
there's that little but we just suppress
it we suppress that [ __ ] right here it
never makes it out the [ __ ] throat
that's why you have a girl sometimes i
gotta look yeah yeah yeah you you really
smart
and the girl hasn't said [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah you look like you got a great
personality
shut up eat to my heart the instagram
unless you're promoting your business
i'm not mad at them i know exactly what
they talking about because some women do
look for followers on instagrams my
suspicion often times and i actually
like it when girls have an instagram is
i can go check their socials to see if
they're real or if they're crazy or
whatnot yeah so i'm not always mad at
seeing the instagram inside the thing
but some women are there to advertise
for sure
personally monica was the best she had a
lot of different looks in her profile
clear we have a dress video thing a
monster with a friend in the fridge i
just moved
so we're only swapping
right here she seems cold
like we're looking for dateables i think
we
i think we got it
[Music]
grace
kristen
gloria molly
monica
oh wow
sorry questions
what was your guy's disorder that was
the reason for switching yeah yeah wait
wait what did you guys put can you guys
like if you guys could stand in the
order
i think i was third
like
is this number one so one yeah one's
okay one third oh i have a question of
course how did you guys define
okay so for example collectively we said
that i think you put donor yet
so you're not sure what you really want
so it's like why commit to someone who's
not sure what they want i didn't think
guys were gonna place that much emphasis
on like my little
don't know yet tag it's just because i
actually don't know what i'm looking for
it makes me think more about what if i
had changed it would i have better
matches and better okay okay okay okay
okay okay i gotta i gotta i gotta
concede something right now and be very
honest with everybody okay
most of this comes down to your pictures
okay they're gonna pontificate now i'm
gonna be like because that's the game
yeah that's the right thing right that's
just it's about how attractive you are
but really that's a 95 percent of it
okay all those other points like listen
her tag and this is that i promise you
if it was the first girl the super you
know hot black girl right there who had
said don't know yet
she might not have been first but she
wouldn't have been fifth okay so just
remember that this is a lot of like um
for the camera yeah cause that's what
they're being asked
so i'm not mad at it but just know if
you're watching this and you're like oh
i gotta change all this thing and that's
gonna make my
it's marginally gonna change things okay
there's some tweaks you can make that
will weed out a couple of people maybe
help folks make the first move based off
your profile but it really just comes
down to how good looking you are and how
your pictures are destroys me you can be
on these profiles put literally nothing
in your profile you got nice pictures
they're still going to match with you
why tinder we think of it as a hookup
app
you know yeah so all the other apps
everyone's like looking for something
and i just
want to enjoy a connection with someone
that's so funny our definitions of
datability were totally different yeah
and then we also thought that you guys
weren't going to care about which dating
happens
all right so you put your instagram bio
in there what can i ask why um it's easy
because people don't think i'm real and
i'm like oh here's my ain't that what i
[ __ ] said yeah absolutely 100 yeah
because these guys are amateurs in the
game they didn't been i've been on the
dating app since plenty of fish since
[ __ ] high five since myspace you get
what i'm saying that's what you're
saying so i've been i've been on them
[ __ ] high five yeah
high fives
together yeah when i was in high school
high five was a [ __ ] yeah yeah for like
a year and then it stopped daddy yeah
you can't even find high five anymore
because usually from a guy's end we
usually think either they're just trying
to get like followers or it's like i've
seen a lot like in the bio it's like if
you think that then you check the
instagram to see what kind of instagram
it is if it's an influencer type
instagram then assume so yeah but if she
just got a regular rinky dink instagram
which is her with her friends and family
i'm not gonna be there like man this
[ __ ] trying to gain followers what a
dumb way to gain followers yes
but especially if you ain't gotten in to
follow yeah
yeah so shout outs to her you know what
girl if you're watching i want to show
you some love you didn't do the wrong
thing i have a question what apps do you
guys use for a relationship
oh okay yeah if i'm looking for a
relationship should i get off a tinder
yes really
i actually hate dating apps i despise
them i think it's very hard to build a
genuine connection for girls i hear all
the time why i want a beard and he has
to be tall and he has to beat this but
it's just like
go where you know the person who wants
you for one and do they treat you right
do they treat your friends right do they
treat the waitress at the restaurant
right you know like just
yo miguel
stop making sense okay you're out here
talking logic about what people should
be into what you should look for stop it
these people she wants chad with the
beard
that's what she wants that's it somebody
trying to hear about your [ __ ] values
and look for a personality like ugh
i want a dude who i could introduce to
my girlfriends and my family so i can
look good yeah
ain't no girl be asking like oh so
what's this person i was like [ __ ] show
me a photo
all right well that's it for today's
video what are your thoughts no
don't you do online dating no
you would have done great no